Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two. David P.. This is
a really funny voicemail. This is someone
who is admonishing me. This caller says,
I had better start telling the truth
about Trump's rally crowds. Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Hey, David, I'm calling about your
Monday show. I think you and other journalists
are doing a disservice to I don't even know
if it's democracy by not showing the number
of people showing up to these Trump rallies.
Speaker 1: Right. But now listen to the
turnaround here. It's not what you expect.
Speaker 6: It was clear from Monday's show
that when the people were being interviewed in
the hallway and in the greeting hallway of Trump's
CPAC rally, there just weren't that many people
around. But what was really obvious was when you
were panning the audience of his rally and the
in the front row seats were clearly not filled.
Plus the venue that he was speaking at, it didn't
look like a big venue. It looked like a venue,
like a small movie theater in
suburbia or something like that.
Anyway, I look forward to watching your show every
day, but I do think that that should be rectified.
Speaker 1: You were completely right. You
were completely right. I did not point out
that, you know, Trump claimed there were a million
people at his rally on January 6th that were not.
Trump claimed there were 30000 people at the
rally I covered, I believe it was on June 26th,
or maybe it was the July 3rd rally. And
it is absolutely true that his crowds
have just been weak. But I want to restate
this. The fact that people aren't right now
energized to go out and see Trump speak in public
means nothing about the fact that this guy still
owns and controls and is the primary individual
in the Republican Party. Let's not forget that,
because if we just fall for the small crowd
stuff, that's how Trump ends up winning again.
And I would say none of us some people in
the audience do want that. For the most part,
most of my audience recognizes that for
the house of horrors that it would be.
We have a great bonus show for you today. It's a
great one. I'm out of time, but just sign up at
join Pakman dot com and it'll be a surprise. But
it's a fantastic bonus. So we have planned to.